he's mr fox sports co-host of first
things first on fox sports one and
what's right with nick wright on
siriusxm good morning nick how are you
good morning dan what an honor to be on
this show the first time i
technically i've been on once before but
it's when that goofball chris mannix was
hosting so it doesn't count
so i'm so excited thank you for having
me on dan uh let's talk about dak
prescott
and this contract here no i'm just
kidding we don't have to thanks
oh you do yeah i got that no give me
your help
give me your ticket top 10 is about
right i'd say somewhere from the 8 to 12
range the
worry is you want to pay the 8th to 12th
best quarterback in football
like he's the best quarterback in
football and if you want me to expand
for two and a half hours on that i can
do it
let's get to lebron james sure yeah i
mean legacy on the line
uh obviously if they win the title
people put an asterisk if not
people will say it totally counts the
asteroids conversation all about him
what else you got i can spit fire these
two oh i know
i know um you know that you know we were
talking about dak prescott here and i
said i don't know if he'll ever have the
numbers to live
up to his contract i think this will be
about winning
um and like russell wilson it's about
winning it's not about
gaudy numbers there are other
quarterbacks who will have that
i i think that dak prescott has to win
and that'll validate everything what do
you think i
i think that's about right i guess it
just depends on what do we
is winning only winning a super bowl
because that's going to be a tough putt
does winning mean consistently winning
the division
making the conference championship game
which the cowboys haven't been in the
quarter century
is that is is that bar if he clears that
does he validate it probably
i just feel like listen every team
in the nfc has been to a super bowl this
century
except for washington detroit
at least a conference championship game
to center washington detroit and dallas
they just they have this air of
greatness because
you know some folks talk about them all
the time i don't know who they are that
they haven't necessarily earned
over the last 25 years so if they get to
a conference championship game
it's a hell of an accomplishment would
jerry jones fire himself
so how about this if stephen had done
the job jerry did
jerry would have fired his son yeah no
question in my mind
right like so the e the closest person
in the world to him
had done this job he'd have been removed
a long time ago so yes i agree
i don't know if it's because you have to
do this every day like i do
and i don't know if it's felt like a
blur or it feels like it's just been
interminable
how would you sum up the last three
months
i would say the first
everything pre george floyd felt
like almost a day-to-day grind that all
blurred together it was slow but it was
hard to differentiate days
and you know since may 25th
i would say for me personally i've gone
through such
a roller coaster of being as depressed
despondent and hopeless as i've maybe
ever felt as an adult
watching the nightly police brutality
like it was a feature film
and then almost immediately around the
time
that goodell released his statement and
then mitt romney is saying black lives
matter
and then it feels like oh my god where
there was no movement for a few years
now
all of a sudden people are getting it
and that has made me feel hopeful
but then you have moments like last
night and it's like hey by the way
there's a noose in bubba wallace's
locker and it's like damn it man
but i to me the i said i separate
chronovirus
into pre and post george floyd because
for a month there
the global pandemic wasn't even the
biggest story in the world
i know you've mentioned this we're
talking to nick wright co-host of first
things first on fox sports one
uh your friendship with colin kaepernick
and uh
the the last time you spoke to him and
are
will we will we have anything coming
from colin kaepernick that would be
football related
anytime soon i don't know i'll be
totally candid that the last time
colin and i spoke was because this is
the type of person he is
about a month into the pandemic he
reached out to me
and said nick nessa and i just want to
make sure you
and your wife and kids are doing okay do
you need anything
that was the last time he and i had
communication that was obviously pre
what roger goodell said i reached out to
him after what roger goodell said
and i and i haven't heard back but that
is not that
surprising our relationship has really
never been based about his football
career
and so i almost felt a little
embarrassed even asking him but i felt
like i had an obligation if he wanted to
say something i
i think the he he gave his statement
that people
you know maybe wasn't perfectly
delivered when he did that tryout
and he said stop running i i do think
it would be in his best interest if he
gave another statement
along the lines of we've now had pete
carroll say they should have signed me
anthony lynn said i should be worked out
the commissioner has no problem with it
i'm available to be worked out i think
what he and his agent would tell you is
they know he's available he's been
available he's wanted to play for the
last three years
just because the rest of the world's
catching up to his cause doesn't mean
there's more of an onus on him
and i didn't know how he would take this
nick because i looked at it and said
well
what has changed people's perception
maybe
or maybe they've they've come to the
realization that
they were the ones he was blackballed
kaepernick hasn't changed he's just
gotten older here
and he's got to look at this and go wait
you're going to
have me come back and are you really
going to give me now you're going to
give me a legitimate tryout
but is it going to feel like a
legitimate tryout for him
listen there is such immense mistrust
on both sides here i know i know that
some of
his biggest advocates behind the scenes
in the league
felt betrayed by the lawsuit now i don't
know if they should have but i know that
they did some folks that were like man
we were working
on your behalf because we saw what was
going on i know
colin feels like the tryout
was a total sleight of hand set up just
to
undercut future lawsuits and i and i
actually think that tryout
which maybe it was an olive branch maybe
it was an olive branch with some strings
attached
set this further back that if if that
had never
happened maybe we would be closer along
and i i do think from a football
perspective one thing i'll say is
for a long time when folks didn't want
to acknowledge being blackballed people
said well
he's too good to be a backup well that's
probably not true anymore he's out of
football for three years
well i think he's going to be too
expensive well i don't believe that's
true anymore either because he's drawn
zero dollars from the nfl for three
years i don't think he's going to be
like
10 million bucks or i'm not playing and
the last one was
your backup needs to stylistically be
similar to your starter now i
don't know that i ever believed that
lamar stepped in for flacco and they
took off
but if that is true we now have a third
of the league
with kind of a dual threat quarterback
we have more starters like that than
ever
my defending champion chiefs have a dual
threat quarterback
their backup's chad henny he's thrown
five passes in five
years and he's not a dual threat guy so
you would think the football reasons
if those were ever part of the reason he
was out of the league those are opening
up a bit
two-part two-prong question do you think
he gets an offer
and do you think he would accept an
offer
oh i let me answer the second part first
i 100
believe he would accept an offer i
believe that
colin kaepernick did not think he was
sacrificing his career when he started
taking a knee i think he thought he was
he i i don't think many of us thought
well he's going to be thrown out of
football he's going to be blackballed i
and in the in the months leading up to
the 2017
season if you said i think he's being
blackballed you were called a fool
you were said no it's money or it's
wait for someone to get hurt or well
he's got to learn the system and then
jacoby percent got traded for and played
eight days later
it was all these things and so i think
colin
has put his money in his actions where
his mouth is on what
what matters to him but i know for a
fact he
loves football and i don't think he ever
believed
i'm never going to be able to run out of
that tunnel again i don't think it ever
occurred to him
there i think he thought what i thought
there's not enough quality quarterbacks
dude was in the super bowl two years
prior like he's he's going to get a job
there might be a few teams that say we
don't want him
and so yes i believe he would absolutely
jump on an opportunity to play
i don't think it's zero percent he gets
the opportunity like i would have told
you
three weeks ago but i don't think it's
good i don't think it's above
20 percent what i hate hearing nick
is you know doug peterson hey you know
we'd think about bringing him in pete
carroll hey anthony lynn
i want to hear an offer i don't want to
it's like all the people who said you
know we were going to draft russell
wilson you know we thought about taking
russell
but you didn't so i don't want to hear
that people hey we'd be open to it
well then do it i don't want to hear it
almost like you're covering your ass
here
yeah and there's also there's always
been a level of dishonesty
in this whole conversation because now
that black lives matter is no longer uh
well it's still controversial statement
but it's but you've got the majority of
american support and people are
no longer trying to change the message
on the kneeling and forget the history
that he started kneeling
as you know very well know because nate
boyer said hey this will resonate better
nate boy or a
navy seal or i'm sorry green beret uh
will resonate better
than sitting and now what you hear is
folks love to bring up two things
the socks and the shirt and it like
that's the new thing and i just maybe i
missed the memo
where police became the one group of
people we can't poke fun at
lawyers and used car salesmen would have
loved to know there are jobs that are
off limits to make fun of there's a
whole industry of lawyer jokes
and then the other one is all right well
the castro shirt and
and i love hearing people talk about the
castro shirt right after they do a
segment so excited to see mike tyson's
next fight
who has a chairman mao tattoo like these
people don't actually care about these
things
they just don't like cap and so they're
using d
they're using a different cuddle to use
against
i wonder if you'll get nominated for a
nobel peace prize
and i'm being serious i'm being serious
i i look i i don't know enough about it
other than
if you look at the change that's
happened
and maybe the change that's going to
continue to happen and can we take it
back to
a guy who was who who knelt who took a
knee
i don't know i just i throw that out
there i
i do think where colin was very
consistent
was his his protest
was not about something intangible or
indefinable such as systemic racism
which while is a blight it has its
tentacles and so many different
things it's very hard to unpack his
protest was about a very specific thing
police brutality against
communities of color and a system of
policing that encourages it
and folks didn't want to hear it at the
time but then post george floyd
when we saw even when these police
forces knew they were on camera
couldn't help themselves and by the way
it wasn't just communities of color
there's that poor 75 year old man in
buffalo
the 16 year old girl i think in
cleveland like they i think
all of a sudden folks saw what they
couldn't see during ferguson
during ferguson it was just black folks
getting
beat on and it wasn't just one police
force
and now when you see it nationwide i do
think if we do move towards
nationwide police reform he absolutely
deserves
a tremendous amount of credit for
focusing the conversation there
before i let you go the most serious
question uh some of my guys the danettes
they're kind of split down the middle on
the length you're here
like they would like for you to go back
and maybe
i oh i i should go back this can i tell
you something right now i certainly
should go back as long as i'm doing the
show from my house
and i have to do my hair on my own dan i
my hair was shaved
a year ago look at this this is an
outrage
it's it's ridiculous i every morning i
just
mat it down i don't know what i'm doing
i
also feel like i i'm i look cooler with
the shaved head
um so yeah i'm gonna as soon as i get to
a barber again i'm either gonna have
them fix it or shave it i don't know
which
wait your hair looks immaculate as
always in your wife a stylist
yeah but not hair she does clothes my
wife
yeah free bird i should say yeah free
bird actually is her company yep people
can find her online
uh yes she does clothes she does some
interior decorating
she does not do hair and makeup and so
i'm just
and by the way that my family's out of
town they left me on father's day to go
and spend it with people they like more
so i'm here all by myself
just sitting here talking to you dealing
with this hair
are you lonely um i mean they left
yesterday
i i'm a little i was i was a little down
i was like of all the days you're gonna
leave me a little
father's day sweet but okay whatever it
happens um uh but then
patrick reached out to me and i was like
well this is one of my radio fathers
so it kind of made me it picked me back
up you look a little like
nick cage
yeah i'll take any i look like i always
feel like
other people are like you look like nick
the only one i don't like you know i
know you got to go
there's a soccer player named frank
riebery who people say i look like i
think he's french
but his only really noticeable trait
other than his nose is a facial scar
and i'm like i don't even have that
they're just saying i'm so funny looking
i look like a
guy who everyone's like oh he's the guy
with the scar in his face i don't have a
scar in my face i'm just funny look
keep fighting the good fight there and
uh thank you great great stuff thank you
nick
great to talk to you later all right
that's nick wright co-host of first
things first
on fox sports one and also uh what's
right with nick wright on siriusx on mad
dog channel